some great tips silver state schools
credit union the sponsors of this next
segment prioritizes people over profit
and this year they're not only
continuing that tradition but also
giving back to our community mercedes
sat down with the president and ceo
scott arkiels scott welcome to las vegas
now first of all i want to thank you
ever since i became a member of silver
state schools credit union and my
daughters have become members we have
never experienced a money institution
like we have with you people they are so
great so thank you guys so much for what
you do
that's incredible mercedes and we
appreciate it i really want to
congratulate silver state schools credit
union on 70 years it is such a huge
anniversary tell me a little bit about
it and how
people can become a member because i
think the misconception is you have to
be a teacher to become a member and you
don't as you know we've been guiding our
members on successful financial journeys
for decades and and um it's at silver
state schools credit union you know
almost anyone can become a member and
uh
the way that you can get in obviously is
if you're an educator yes you can become
a member but also if you're a parent of
uh or a guardian of a
student you can also become a a member
and then
one of the easiest and fastest ways too
is if you want to make a one-time
donation to pbs uh which is a great
supporter of uh you know of ccsd that's
a great way to get into um you know the
education community as well and and to
become a member at silver state schools
credit union so that's one great way to
get in and the slogan that you use and
it's right behind you prioritizing
people over profit you feel that when
you get in you are a part of your you're
a member you are not just a number and
there's a actually a really great way
that you can earn some cash back at
silver state schools credit union this
holiday season tell me a little bit
about that we actually just revamped our
whole uh silver state school's credit
card and and it's a great thing because
it's a cash rewards credit card so with
that cash rewards credit card uh
it's a program that rewards you every
time that you use your credit card um
and so this holiday season members can
earn 1.5 percent cash back every
purchase every time so you can uh shop
with confidence this holiday season with
service day schools credit unions cash
back rewards credit card it's like you
keep giving and giving to your customers
i love him and not just your customers
to the community yes what are you guys
doing for local students this year
so on behalf of the pop foundation
silver state schools credit union's
annual food and clothing drives now
underway through december 11th to
support our local focus schools so
anyone in the community can help by
donating items at any one of our 10
branch locations and so we're asking for
canned goods and non-perishable food
items new and gently used coats new
socks and undergarments as well as
toiletries for school-aged children and
this is one of the biggest events that
we have and it's amazing even in
troubled times
you know people give so much out of
their out of their pocket for uh for
these kids that are uh in need of of
these sayings and so we really
appreciate that and so we encourage
people to give
thanks to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring this segment get
one and a half percent cash back with a
ssscu credit card for more information
call 702 733 8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com
las vegas now we will be right back